it's my great pleasure and honor to
introduce Matthew Winkler the founder of
Bloomberg News and its editor-in-chief
emeritus since 2015 I'm delighted he has
agreed to be here to deliver the
luncheon speech of the center and
capitalism society and societies 14th
annual conference matthew winkler link
Winkler is an unparalleled figure in
American news in 1990 he co-founded
Bloomberg News with Michael Bloomberg
over the next 25 years he went on to
transform the company into an
international media empire with 150
bureaus in 73 countries employing 2,300
writers and editors Bloomberg News
includes a global television network
radio station website subscription-only
newsletters and two magazines Bloomberg
Businessweek and Bloomberg Markets prior
to the co-founding Bloomberg News Matt
was a reporter and editor first at the
Mount Vernon news in Ohio interesting to
know whether that's still around it is
okay then at the bond buyer and later at
the Wall Street Journal and barons
between 1991 and 1994 Matt also wrote
the capital markets column for Forbes
magazine he's the co-author of the book
Bloomberg by Bloomberg and the author of
the Bloomberg way which has been called
the news services Bible so without
further ado I welcome you to matthew
winkler
[Applause]
Thank You professor Phelps for that very
generous introduction and it's a it's a
pleasure to be with you I should say I
come to this meeting as you just learned
as a journalist and I'm focused on
corporate economic and investment data
that's been my specialty in application
for many decades now and I'm
particularly interested in that data as
a way to provide a perspective of the
past year which i think is his why
professor Phelps actually asked me to
come because as we all know there was an
election recently and the outcome was
something of a surprise and already
missing probably from the narrative of
this momentous event is that only five
times in American history has the winner
of the popular vote been a loser and if
the estimates are accurate and it looks
like by the day they are Clinton will
have won the vote by a margin of more
than two million votes and they're still
piling up in California as we speak but
as you know the media my profession has
a tendency to favor winners whoever they
are regardless of the circumstances in
this election so far shows no deviation
from that tendency and I say this
because the historical fact of more
Americans voting for Clinton by such a
significant margin might help explain
the data that i'm about to share with
you that as I said was mostly missing
from the narrative the discussion over
the past year the first and I want to
thank my colleague Sasha graph was my
chief of staff for being able to present
these slides as I show them to you
the GDP of major economies over the past
30 years is what you're looking at the
u.s. is the Green Line eurozone is
yellow china which as you know is still
a developing economy not a developed
economy is red but I put that in here
because it's number two Japan is white
Germany is orange UK is blue and Canada
is pink and as you can see from this
picture in front of you there's only one
line that is going up the rest have
rolled over since I like to say the
worst recession since the Great
Depression I know everybody likes to use
that word great recession but I think it
confuses more than clarifies it was the
worst recession since the Great
Depression and probably comes closest
were it not for the intervention of
policy makers of being another Great
Depression and that's why it's worth
showing here and then a bigger snapshot
is what's happened since 2008 the u.s.
is the only major developed economy the
only major developed country with record
GDP since 2008 again the US is green
eurozone is yellow Japan is white
Germany is orange UK is blue and Canada
is pink I dare say at no point on any
nightly news Morning News evening news
online in the whole discussion of
whether the US economy this past year
was there ever the mention even
parenthetically that the u.s. is the
only developed economy in the world that
has record GDP so that's why I share
that with you okay no one has pointed
that out and again I'm not an economist
I am just a newspaper man really that's
where I began and all I do is just
observe the data as it presents itself
now let's turn to the workforce
the numbers number of workers in the
u.s. to assemble motor vehicles in parts
increased forty-eight percent from six
hundred and twenty-three thousand people
in june 2009 which you could argue was
the worst point of the recession to nine
hundred and thirty-two thousand
currently and that's according to the
bureau of labor statistics and as you
can see it's quite a dramatic
improvement from where we were that's a
forty-eight percent increase in the
number of workers assembling motor
vehicles and parts now let's just oppose
that let's go to another one the number
of workers in the US construction
industry increased twenty-three percent
from 5.4 million in 2011 to the current
6.7 million and then again that's
according the bureau of labor statistics
and again i'm sharing with you data that
is empirically verified that is
instantly replicated and so far i think
you will agree with me rarely did this
data ever get into broadcast news at any
time in the discussion of whether the US
in 2016 the next piece of data is total
employment in the United States and this
is non-farm payrolls and this increased
ten percent during this same period
since june 2009 and the current total is
a hundred and forty five million jobs
now just put these three pictures in
perspective the big picture of course is
non-farm payrolls went up ten percent so
that's everybody's jobs all thrown into
the same mix up ten percent the Bert the
specific group of workers that did the
best under President Obama happened to
be people who were making cars and
construction just for what it's worth
okay and I'm just showing you data that
was their next slide is since Obama took
office in 2009 and you remember
that year the pessimism was pretty
prevalent to say the least the stock
market as measured by the sp500 probably
hit it slow around the first week of
march two thousand nine very few people
were bullish on the u.s. there was only
one major investor in fact who was and
that was Warren Buffett and you recall
he had just bought some railroads which
gave you some idea where he thought
things were going but in any case he
bought some railroads and manufacturing
jobs since that time increased seven
percent now you might think that that's
a relatively small number and in some
ways it is but it happens to be the
biggest percentage increase during one
president's tenure since the eight
percent increase when Lyndon Johnson was
president between 1963 and 1968 so
another piece of context and perspective
I think that was missing from the
political narrative now let's go to
trade which unfortunately was
essentially given up as a subject any
kind of redeeming value and trade free
trade as the trade deficit of goods
since 2011 is what we're looking at
trade surplus of services is still
growing and we look at the wage over
labor grows eight percent since 2011
service wage gains fifty fifteen percent
I just want to pause and look at this
for a second because this is a rather
complicated chart we have a trade
surplus of services trade surplus of
services one of the biggest components
of us trade is our services often
completely missed in the discussion of
trade nafta everything else one of the
big exports that we have in this country
is our services this is crazy surplus of
forty-one percent the trade deficit of
goods more or less continues in a
predictable pattern
service wages gained fifteen percent as
overall wages gained eight percent I'm
not making a judgment here but I am just
sharing with you a reality which is that
America still is an exporter but one of
the things that exports is services
again I found it hard to find any kind
of sober discussion of that at any point
even in print journalism on a daily
basis so so far we have this conclusion
blue collar you want to call them that
blue collar workers go back to work to
get jobs faster than any other type of
industry many blue collar workers may
have moved to the service industry where
there are higher and arguably greater
opportunities for compensation
accelerating compensation that's what
those slides suggest so now let's look
at back to GDP when we look at GDP
growth of the u.s. it's been slowing to
one and a half percent this year its
projected to grow 2.1 percent in the
next two years however then one thing
that we try to do at Bloomberg is look
at everything in the context of relative
value the only way one can understand
anything is its relative value so when
we look at where the u.s. is relative to
everybody else in the world and we're
looking at the developed economies
slowing down is obviously a big problem
in a big issue but the u.s. is still
performing better than any developed
economy so far and you know I've
highlighted the u.s. category and green
but if you look at every country
mentioned here Germany the UK France
Canada Italy Japan and Russia you can
see that not only in 16 but 17 and 18
the performance isn't is good so now
let's turn to a favorite subject of mine
and I know a lot of economists
infrastructure in government spending
and I want to turn specifically to of
all places Colorado because it's a
really good example I think of what
happens when infrastructure is done in a
very big way and how does it affect the
economy Colorado you may recall in the
1980s when federico pena was the mayor
of Denver was actually losing population
for the first time in its history as a
state it was losing population Denver
was a shadow of its former self and the
outlook was bleak by the late 80s and
the mayor with a very bipartisan group
of people businessmen put forth a
proposal to create what would be when
turns out to be the first and only major
new airport since dallas-fort worth in
the early 70s the Denver International
Airport at the time it ran into much
criticism it was considered a boondoggle
crandall when he was the CEO and
chairman of American Airlines actually
ridiculed it as a field of dreams and
said nobody would come we don't need an
airport but if you look at what's
happened to the state of Colorado which
is of course in the middle of the United
States landlocked it's actually punched
way above its weight ever since then
what you have here is non-farm payrolls
1996 to 2016 and then you have Colorado
up thirty-seven percent when the US was
up twenty percent when we look at home
value appreciation in Colorado it beats
the country the home value of Colorado
appreciated a hundred and thirty-seven
percent since 1996 when the measure same
measure for the country was ninety-five
percent so by the way if you go to the
Denver International Airport today it's
one of the less than 20 in the united
states where there are daily flights to
Asia to Europe and Central America hard
to say that about us you know anywhere
that's number 22 in population
but it's an example of what a difference
infrastructure can make in transforming
an economy and it's not just Democrats
who say that Republicans as well in the
state of Colorado interestingly enough
in the whole year of campaigning and
people talking about infrastructure I
don't think the Denver Airport was
mentioned once I don't think Colorado
was mentioned once it is a very
interesting state because it is the
number one destination for baby boomers
and Millennials alike and that kind of
tells you something right there okay
let's turn to one of my favorite
subjects Wall Street there was a lot of
bashing of Wall Street this year and you
know we're at 2008 I suspect it would be
entirely legitimate but it's now 2016
and what we can show when we look at the
things that Wall Street deals with is
that household debt burden is way down
home equity values have come back loans
are more available just look at the
Federal Reserve data of banks
willingness to lend and the badly a bad
loan ratio is down as well so Americans
right now this slide that you're looking
at are within five percentage points of
the all-time-high valuation of their
homes in 2006 now everybody knows how
terrible the financial crisis was how
devastating it was so to understand and
it was the first time by the way in our
lifetimes that housing values actually
went down everybody until 2008 believed
that your home was secure and it would
see nothing but appreciation now and in
the hereafter obviously that wasn't true
but if we look at where we are today you
can see that there's been a dramatic
recovery in people's biggest possession
another piece of data that's interesting
which is household debt payments as a
percentage of disposable income have
plummeted to ten percent from 13 point
twenty two percent in 2007 now that's a
really important data because that says
that Americans are actually in a better
situation in terms of debt than they've
been in a very
long time a very long time they're
healthier let's turn back to labor the
labor participation rate has gone up to
60 two-point-eight percent from 60 2.4%
not great numbers you might say except
that this twelve-month gain ending last
month is the biggest advance since 1989
and you know as a newsman I always get
what what gets my attention or
superlatives so that's a pretty
interesting superlative that you would
see that kind of dramatic increase since
1989 needless to say I think you'll
agree with me almost everything I've
shared with you so far you didn't even
see debated on anybody's news now let's
turn to my favorite state California
which I referenced at the outset of this
this discussion when 2015 the gross
domestic product of California advanced
five point seven percent to 2.5 trillion
dollars that makes it one seventh of the
US economy there are 50 states
California is one-seventh of those 50
states in terms of GDP the rest of the
US by the way gained just two-point-six
percent in 2015 so what's the
significance of this okay you you read a
lot and heard a lot about North Carolina
you read a lot and heard a lot about
Michigan in Ohio and Pennsylvania in
Florida California created more jobs
than Texas and Florida combined last
year okay and with this GDP it is now it
is now the fifth largest country in the
world it is supplanted in the past three
years France and the UK and Brazil not
necessarily in that order and because of
brexit and because when you do the math
on what the economic forecasts are this
year and next year for the UK you
calculate the plummeting pound after
Brett
sit you wind up with California's GDP
easily exceeding the UK which it was
behind at this time last year but the
bigger point is this about California it
is really a country and unlike maybe
other parts of this country it is not
polarized okay it is it is a country
where people's preferences in public
policy converge seemingly harmoniously
and again what California means to the
United States in terms of its gdp in
terms of its job growth much of what it
has done in the past year is just
completely missing from anybody's
conversation and as you can see from
this chart you see that california grew
twice as fast as the rest of the united
states another fact about california
during the past five years the companies
big and small in california and what I'm
talking about our Russell 3000 so that's
three thousand companies if you looked
at those companies by every investment
measure we have at Bloomberg okay return
on assets return on equity all of the PE
everything that you can think of
companies domiciled in California
outperform companies in the rest of the
United States over five years and over 1
year really pretty much any period but
this graph right here gives you a sense
of that okay let's turn to dead where we
are with that because we're probably
going to be talking about that for the
next decade increasingly corporations
when we look at us companies today all
US companies again let's take the
Russell 3000 we find that the net debt
ratio to earnings before interest taxes
depreciation amortization that ratio of
companies say from the S&P 500 index it
fell to the lowest point
since at least 1990 when we began
compiling that data which means it
actually may be the lowest ever because
if you think about where interest rates
are today and where they've been this
debt ratio of American companies may be
the lowest ever so what does that mean
it actually means because this ratio is
arguably one of the most conservative
measures of measuring the health of
companies means that American companies
are the healthiest they've been in quite
some time maybe forever again this is a
piece of data that may seem arcane to
many people but in fact it's it's very
interesting in the context of where the
United States is relative to everybody
else you can't find any kind of
performance about corporate britain
corporate france corporate UK corporate
china corporate germany that comes
anywhere near the performance of
corporate america by this measure okay
so what about the American consumer when
we look at the sales per share from
consumer sorry when we is one more thing
I want to point out when we look at this
yeah sales from per share from consumer
discretionary companies in the S&P 500
it's at a record now everybody knows
consumer discretionary companies you
know those are the things we don't need
compared to consumer staples the gap to
the similar measure of consumer staples
companies widened to a record since 2008
that's what this slide shows you now
growing spread could mean that consumers
have the most disposable income to spend
well not posting inflation concerns I
won't make that judgment leave it to
people here and elsewhere to make that
judgment but this is a very interesting
by the way this is a very interesting
piece of data to tell us sort of where
we are so all I wanted to do was
elaborate a little bit on a conversation
i had with Professor phelps many months
ago
like so many of us the mood at the
meeting where we were at was pretty
gloomy we of course did not know where
things would end with the election but
we were just like many people ruminating
over seemingly how angry everybody was
in despondent and so on and yet there
was plenty of data in our midst that
says well things may not be great
they're a lot better than where they
were thank you very much there's time
plenty of time for questions yes you got
one right here you get my idea you spoke
about us compared to Europe which Europe
doesn't do well in a lot of ways could
you think some more about a two percent
growth that we've been experiencing
relative to should it have been four
percent and if so why the difference
okay the eye that question is about why
not four percent instead of two percent
is that right and the answer can't
possibly come from me because I'm just a
newsman and I just report on what I see
which is data I try to become
illuminated by talking to people like my
good friend professor Phelps dr. Phelps
and he has as you well know a very
articulate theory and explanation about
why we're not at four percent all I do
or try to do is just share with people
as much data that is relevant to the
discussion as possible that's all I can
do so I can't give you an answer that
you're seeking you're going to have to
get that from a much brighter light here
than me nobody breaded and you
half adma boundary which is when I look
at myself I feel miserable but when I
compare myself to others then I feel
heartened when you look at the
electorate's of Trump and Clinton it's I
don't think that these are a coincidence
that the electorate of Clinton is on the
east and the west coast and the Tramp
electorate is in the center America ok
is much much more inward-looking here
and my my my just by my opinion is that
the fact that the new president of the
United States has been elected by such
an inward-looking electorate is a
problem for the united states and even
them even the more more more serious
problem for the rest of the world I
think that's undoubtedly true everything
you just said and my favorite aunt used
to say after we snapped a picture of her
just give it five years and it'll look
great but all kidding aside I think
that's partially true about the election
although I would qualify it Nevada is
not on the west coast Colorado is not on
the west coast New Mexico is not on the
west coast Arizona was closer than it's
been a very long time the margin of
victory in the so-called battleground
states was as slim as it gets and if you
go back to 2012 the margin of victory
for Obama in the battleground states and
many of them was as slim as it gets so I
think you have to be very careful about
jumping to conclusions about you know
what the electorate is telling you but
here's what we do get from the data the
voters as I said before
very few people are reminding us every
day that she will have won the popular
vote by a margin that may be a record of
more than 2 million votes and and the
people who voted yes they're on the east
coast near on the west coast but those
people we're talking about our recently
multicultural multi-ethnic very diverse
young and old alike male female and
transgender gay and lesbian and that
actually is the future of the 21st
century certainly in America that's
where we're going so I would hesitate to
draw you know some big conclusions just
on the basis of the electoral college
which twice now since 2000 has returned
somebody who got fewer votes than the
winner of the popular vote to the White
House I do think you know the reason why
I wanted to share this data is because i
don't think the electorate has been well
served by the discussion of what's
matters most to them I don't think the
electorate has heard enough from people
who can report to them what the state of
Economic Affairs is even if it's not as
good as it should be or once was
although it's questionable to say you
know where we ever in some kind of
golden age when I was talking to
Professor Phelps about this very issue
you know I grew up in the 60s and I
remember a professor Senate in fact
referenced him a southern politician
George Wallace who had a very successful
slogan stand up for america sound
familiar and he did very well he won
Michigan in fact he won the state of
Michigan he won the state of Michigan
when Michigan had an all-time high
employment of everybody putting out
automobiles okay that was the best we
ever did in the 1960s and George Wallace
one Michigan so I think there's
something more going on here than sort
of an economic backdrop which the media
likes to equipment in this box and I
don't think
it's really as accurate as as it
suggested Padma professor decide I
believe that so far monetary policy had
to take the entire burden of propping up
the economy since 2008 from the deep
recession budgetary policy in the form
of expanding federal expenditures did
not have much of a role because the
republican-dominated Congress would not
agree to budget to President Obama's
proposals of federal expansion of
federal budgetary spending do you think
that now we have a Republican president
designate and a republican-dominated
Congress this situation would change
that fiscal policy would take some of a
role of propping up the economy thank
you again I'm not qualified to make that
judgment or provide that assessment can
say this the one thing these both both
of these candidates had in common was a
commitment to infrastructure and many
economists have written quite
significantly about how important
infrastructure in the United States is
and how constructive it might be so I
like to think that you know maybe we'll
get lucky here better better lucky than
smart that we will see a fiscal policy
that may have the impact what would
worry me though is if we have huge tax
cuts at the same time that we have
massive spending and we sort of been
there before and that's not a recipe for
long-term growth I'm not the only one
saying that by the way I'm just
repeating what what's been said so yeah
I'm hopeful I will say this about
monetary policy in the almost three
years maybe it's longer than that that
Janet Yellen has been chair of the
Federal Reserve you've had even with
recent events the lowest volatility in
the debt market of any Fed chair going
all the way back to Paul Volcker okay no
granted she didn't inherit the high
interest rate regime that Alan Greenspan
did but it says something about the
competence of the Fed under Janet Yellen
the first woman by the way made share of
the Fed in its hundred year history that
there was so much stability in the
period that she took over as Fed chair
you have any disaggregated wage data
that might indicate that there are
pockets of the population that are kind
of stuck I don't have specifically that
data but I'm sure we can get it yet a
look there are there are certain
industries I'm not saying anything that
isn't obvious there are certain
industries in the country particularly
where I think you come from where there
has been a traumatic shift of coal for
example and people's lives have been
completely disrupted for the worse
because of it it's by no means the only
example but it's a good one and it helps
explain why West Virginia as a state is
you know been convulsed politically the
way it has that unfortunately is a fact
of our time you know when people talk
about you know NAFTA as being you know
the enemy I don't think NAFTA ever was
the job creator or or the job killer
that either its enthusiasts or its
detractors suggested what it did do is
it made the US and Canada and Mexico
much more efficient and the proof of
that the proof of the US Canada Mexico
connection being much more efficient as
a region is that when you look at the
automobile industry today in the United
States
it is actually today the most profitable
of any automobile industry anywhere in
the world which is why everybody who
makes automobiles or assembles them
wants to be in the United States whether
it's BMW making most of if not all of
the SUV's that it makes for the world in
Spartanburg South Carolina or suv's
coming out of Alabama from Mercedes it's
why nissan is in smyrna tennessee and
Toyotas in Covington Kentucky and of
course Hunt has been in Marysville Ohio
since the 70s so everybody who makes
cars and assembles them wants to be in
the US why is that well one the market
is pretty profitable as I said compared
to everywhere else the other is the
efficiency you can do more in the US
market than you can do anywhere else so
none of what I just said was shared in
any debate and any discussion about
NAFTA over the past year
Georgetown Kentucky so I head stringham
economist Trinity College per game at
Georgia Kentucky you're absolutely right
thank you hi my name is Ned stringing
from Trinity College in Connecticut I
was just curious charge but I'm curious
how you started I decided where the x
axis started some of them were 2009 some
of them were 2011 if we want to actually
look at an accurate depiction of what
happened over the years why weren't you
choosing 2008 2 2016 where we might have
priced policies of the current president
into them as they started and then I'm
also curious to know how you decided to
have a positive or a negative assessment
so you showed about how there's a lack
of corporate debt in America today and
you said oh this is amazing and a lot of
other people would say this is terrible
companies can't have access to debt
private equity firms have highly
leveraged companies and they're
outperforming publicly traded firms
because publicly traded firms don't have
access to debt and great great questions
and let's take the ladder first what I
showed you was the debt ratio which is
different from debt the debt ratio is a
way to calculate essentially is the
company able given all kinds of risks to
deal with those risks going forward it
is not a date a point that says this is
the level of debt that a company has so
it's a very important distinction okay
so that that's why we use the debt ratio
not to show you essentially the level of
borrowing of a company but to show you
how that company is operating with the
debt that it has so that and by the way
that is not an original if you will
analysis that's something that I think
in in all business schools when they
look at you know how you look at
companies that's one way to measure it
now in terms of data points and where we
started the first one goes all the way
back 30 years so this is the big one the
big picture of gdp the reason why I
picked 2009 in some cases because I was
trying to say okay
this is a political year in were
measuring the performance of the most
recent occupant so might as well start
when he started which was in 2009 simple
as that I wasn't trying to be clever in
any way but we could have we could have
started in 2008 if you like but that's
why we picked 2009 in terms of other
years like 2011 we were looking at when
did we start seeing the beginning of the
recovery you know the worst of the
recession was in 2009 the recovery
started to be evident in 2010 but it was
really in 2011 that we started to see
enough evidence to say this really is a
recovery and its unmistakable so those
were the assumptions they weren't you
know for anything other than that that's
the reason you don't mean do I go what
do you think is the role of the media in
particular channels like Fox News and
creating maybe a false perception of
these data and a nation that is
incapable of compromising and the
government and I think as one whole I
come from a very old fashioned school of
best practices starting with if it isn't
true it isn't news show don't tell which
means instead of telling people what
what is happening show them what is
happening with anecdotes examples data
to me that enables us to get closest to
what is accurate I think it's impossible
to find the truth that's almost you know
like searching for the deity but there
is a way to inform people with facts and
figures and context and perspective it's
a combination of language
and arithmetic and you know
unfortunately we're in the age truth and
the age of Twitter is horribly
compromised you know misinformation and
information are constantly competing
with each other in some ways the
opportunity for journalism is better
than it's ever been because we have
technological tools to get at data like
the type that I showed you and even if
somebody quibbles with it or it takes
issue with its validity at least it's a
starting point and the discussion should
be data-driven is what I'm saying and
the more data-driven the discussion is
the less emotional it is the less
ideological it is and i hope the more
informative it is last question or two
going going gone yes microphone stand up
give your name please my name is Dallas
Galvin and what I'm asking about is if
you think about it data as we all know
in academia depends on on the
perspective you want the data that you
given suggests that everything is kind
of peachy keen oh and that the media
didn't mention those things when you
talk about infrastructure are you
thinking because this is a conference on
the working class that somehow or
another there will be so many more jobs
that working-class people can get
together form unions and actually have a
real income because clearly they don't
have an income otherwise it wouldn't
have voted the way they did it isn't a
question just not enough information
which I agree with you in the media they
look at their paychecks every week and
they know they're not doing well
what's the question what was what's the
question my question is in the
microphone please okay sorry the what
you suggest is that the growth of
infrastructure investment is somehow or
another going to change things and what
I'm saying is that the people who voted
more than likely for Trump but in any
case who vote every day by going to the
bank and looking at their paychecks know
that this data that you've just shown is
divine if you happen to be in the
100,000 up category but for regular
people the reason they voted against
mrs. Clinton is in large measure because
they didn't feel that they were okay are
you the infrastructure yeah increase
will cause more Union involvement and
therefore an increase in real salaries
and real okay delicately I'll give you
an example of what I'm talking about and
and I think everybody in this room
actually can relate to it first of all I
would say infrastructure is not a
panacea and it never will be there
happens to be however a growing
accelerating need for infrastructure
spending and improvement because our
roads our bridges and I don't need to go
any further are in such disrepair not to
mention lots of schools and hospitals
and so on so it would be to our benefit
as an economy to have these institutions
fixed for the better and one of the
byproducts or benefits of course is that
will put a lot of people to work who
otherwise wouldn't be working now let me
give you the example that's right here
in our backyard in 2009 the US
government thanks to frank Lautenberg
had passed legislation that enabled the
state of New Jersey for the first time
to get money back in a big way that it
had been giving to Wyoming
and what I'm talking about was the
infrastructure plan to build a new
tunnel under the Hudson River now the
year is 2009 we're in the depths of
depression okay I think even people like
Professor Phelps and ya would agree that
was a good time to build a bridge in a
tunnel that was a really good time for
New Jersey it was a really good time
because the economy was in desperate
shape the housing industry was a
shambles just the commitment to build
that tunnel in 2009 would have had a
knock-on effect for the housing industry
for business and everything else the
governor the new governor of new jersey
at the time said he was worried about
cost overruns at a time when we were
entering maybe one of the greatest
deflation xin american history when
interest rates were headed for record
lows if ever there was a time to borrow
money 2009-2010 was the period to do it
and the governor of New Jersey said
forget it and we didn't do anything
about it that's why infrastructure
matters and that would have been a
fabulous time to commit and we could
have done it and there was the political
will to do it in Washington it just
didn't happen locally in the state of
New Jersey thank you very much thank you
do let's give them a big hair